Ya.
Bila kita tengok keupayaan hari ini, saya rasa ia juga soalan penting untuk tanya
baiklah, apakah peta jalan tu — berapa banyak
lebih baik sistem-sistem ini
dan berapa jauh lebih kompleks
circuit yang kita mampu laksanakan
dan untuk itu kita telah bangunkan satu metrik yang sangat penting
yang dipanggil quantum volume
kadang-kadang korang mungkin baca atau dengar dalam akhbar popular
bilangan qubit — dan korang tahu
sebagai ukuran kemajuan
saya nak beritahu terus terang bahawa
sekadar bilangan qubit dalam mesin tu bukan
ukuran kemajuan yang bagus
kemajuan perlu diukur dengan
tahap kerumitan circuit yang boleh dilaksanakan
qubit dalam mesin-mesin yang baik ini tidak sempurna hari ini
dan ia ada ralat yang diperkenalkan oleh gandingan
sistem dengan dunia luar
kuasa sebenar qubit-qubit ini
— entanglement dan sifat-sifat tersebut —
itulah juga yang menjadikan mereka berkuasa
sekaligus rapuh terhadap gangguan
dan hubungan dengan dunia luar
jadi kita perlu turunkan kadar ralat
sambil tingkatkan bilangan qubit
itulah yang digambarkan di sini
apa yang korang betul-betul nak buat ialah bergerak secara pepenjuru
dan quantum volume adalah ukuran yang menggabungkan
kedua-dua metrik tersebut dan beberapa pertimbangan penting tambahan